the world is experiencing some of its
most extreme weather patterns on record
from floods and intense rains to heat
waves and greenhouse gases from human
activity like burning fossil fuels and
generating electricity are contributing
significantly to these hazards
now africa has been responsible for less
than four percent of the emissions but
it is by far the most vulnerable region
to the effects of climate change
among these experts predict that most
parts of the continent will experience
much drier conditions that's already the
case in parts of northern kenya which
have not seen rain for more than a year
dw's correspondent mario miller reports
these mothers have walked for hours to
reach this health facility
they want to have their babies checked
some of these babies are severely
malnourished and their mothers who are
breastfeeding them haven't been able to
eat properly in weeks now they're being
registered here at this health facility
and they hope to receive nutrition
supplements
one of them is adikeno
his upper arm circumference shows that
he is severely malnourished
his mother has only eaten maize meal for
weeks now so her breast milk doesn't
have enough nutrients for her
it gives baby great pain my baby is two
and a half years old and he's too weak
to stand up
health worker gracie lamo has seen a
stream of undernourished children here
in the past months
and there are many other children who
remain without help out there
due to distance not all malnourished
children come here because of the
distance we can't reach out to all of
them it really makes me feel bad
nearly one in five young children in
marsabad county are considered
malnourished
life in the arid region has always been
hard but now marshabit hasn't seen rain
for a whole year
climate change is said to be partly
responsible for that
and it's the children who are suffering
there is a strong relationship between
climate change and the malnutrition and
especially if already there's been
malnutrition
then it escalates
by increasing the numbers and also the
severity
the frequency and severity of droughts
in this region is expected to get worse
due to climate change
a disaster for local pastoralists
their livelihoods depend entirely on
their animals
this camel herder tells us he's been
looking for water for his camels for two
days now
in vain
and these women often have to wait a
whole day just to get water
now there's less water flowing out of
the tap
and that's a day they cannot spend
searching for food
that is when food is available at all
selena musa has hardly anything to feed
her son
it's painful but i have to accept it i
can't feed him properly to give him what
he needs to grow
[Music]
the young mother hopes the reigns will
finally return
now with me is the south african human
rights and environmental activist kumi
naidu kumi started out as a child
activist fighting apartheid in south
africa today his activism is mostly
focused on climate justice he was the
head of greenpeace international until
2016. welcome to dwe news africa comey
we have just seen a report there from
kenya this is a real and current example
of how climate change is impacting lives
um in africa how bad will the situation
get for people on the continent
if the world does not reduce carbon
emissions
we have to recognize firstly that the
decade that we find ourselves in right
now is the most consequential decade in
humanities history
what we do in the next 10 years will
determine what kind of future we'll have
or whether we'll have a future at all
there is far too big a gap between what
climate science is saying and what
extreme weather events are saying on the
one hand and what politics and economics
are saying it's important to recognize
that the african continent has
contributed minimally to the problem of
climate change but we are paying already
the first and the most brutal price from
the impacts of climate change and we
have seen disruptions in agricultural
patterns we've seen as the signs warned
us that will have fast or deep
fluctuations between floods and drought
i mean i grew up in southern africa you
know i don't in my entire memory
remember us having cyclones but last
year you know we had devastating
cyclones in mozambique for example so
the impact already from climate is
taking lives destroying infrastructure
and reshaping the continent so
it's important that we recognize that if
no urgent action is taken now
things will get much much worse for
people on the african continent
as we're reporting world leaders uh will
soon be gathering at the cop 26 climate
summit in glasgow let's have a listen
now to some people in africa telling us
what they would like for world leaders
to keep in mind
as a farmer i lost already some of my
livestock because of the droughts i hope
that global leaders in cop 26 come up
with a positive solution
for climate change that we here in
africa didn't even cause
it's true that they create industries in
order to manufacture things that are
very good but let them know how to
create things that
are good that are that that are going to
dilute the gas that is released on the
atmosphere not to affect the human being
existence that's what i can propose
we should be involved in helping to
reduce carbon emissions
they should consider us by forgiving our
debts so that the money can be used from
planting more trees
for for us to deal with the climate
change
okay so some voices uh from the
continent there um it's our
understanding that african negotiators
going into the cop 26 uh summit will be
asking for money
to invest in measures to help africa
adapt to to the climate change issues so
we're talking about money to plant trees
for example like the lady in malawi was
just saying tell us more about these
demands firstly it's important to note
that it's not only african countries
making the demand it's countries in the
global south more generally and
essentially we're not asking for charity
here we're asking rich nations to pay
the climate debt and as an act of
redress because they've created the
problem and that's why you know it's not
only a question of climate injustice
that's why we say it's a question of
climate apartheid that those parts of
the world that contributed most to the
problem were predominantly white and
those that are suffering most are
predominantly people of color and and
and
the rich nations of the world have
failed that test with covert where
they've not
responded as they should so the green
climate fund was an idea that was
already agreed by
cop
that took place in copenhagen in 2009
right the money is not yet flowing
that's right and what cop showed that
rich nation sorry what covert showed is
rich nations can find money when they
need as you can see how much of money
has been found to support their citizens
but what rich nations need to understand
just like with covert
climate does not recognize boundaries so
the short-sightedness that rich nations
have shown up to covert we hope they
eventually come around and understand
that in their interests to support poor
nations in terms of uh climate change
you talked about these commitments being
made as far back as 2009 how are we
going to hold developed countries more
accountable to pay up
well with extreme difficulties the short
answer because they can behave like with
absolute impunity as we've seen
part of the solution is to ensure that
we are
making the citizens in rich countries
aware of what is happening and for them
to recognize that it's in their
self-interest to act and i pay tribute
here to movements like fridays for the
future
the young people have been outstanding
in terms of
provoking
the right kind of conversation and so on
as well as movements like extinction
rebellion that have brought the issue of
urgency to the table so
my faith at the moment is on ordinary
people and making sure ordinary people
in rich countries are able to convince
their governments that they need to be
more generous not because
it's an act of charity but because it's
in the self-interest of rich nations
because we either get this right as rich
and poor countries are acting together
or
true poor countries are going to fall
first and are suffering first but
ultimately the rich countries won't be
protect from it as floods in germany and
in belgium a couple months ago showed
that nobody's
sort of immunized from the impacts of
climate change all right thanks for that
kumi thank you for the moment
[Music]
now cole is the single biggest
contributor to climate change burning
coal mainly to generate power is
responsible for nearly half of the
world's carbon dioxide emissions there
are only some 27 coal fired power
stations in sub-saharan africa
this is a tiny amount compared to the
rest of the world but many fear a
potential cold boom on the continent as
african nations scramble to meet their
power needs now this dilemma is
something south africa is struggling
with as i found out on a recent visit
right in the heart of the small town of
lipalali are two of the engines powering
africa's most industrialized economy
in the background is the ailing matimba
power station which is 30 years old and
nearing the end of its lifespan
and this is medupi the newest addition
to the country's fleet of coal power
plants south africa is one of the most
electrified countries on the continent
but electricity shortages caused by
aging and crumbling infrastructure have
crippled the economy in the last decade
the new power station is crucial but for
some south africans madupi has come at a
high price
you have to know that we live in one of
the most beautiful areas in the world
this is the heart of the bushfire and
suddenly we've got a huge monstrosity
built
right in the center of this beautiful
bushfire these power lines crossing the
countryside there's noise pollution
light pollution and of course
air pollution a lot a lot of air
pollution which the community are
suffering under and the impact goes
beyond the small rural town the two
power stations are 10 kilometers apart
and between them is the main
that supplies them with coal
right over here is the conveyor belt
that transports coal from the main
just behind me over there to madupi
power station ahead of me and matimba on
my left now it is the only mine in le
palale but this region
is home to some of south africa's most
abundant coal reserves in fact
underneath the ground i'm standing on
it's estimated there are billions of
tons of coal here that could take south
africa to the latter part of the century
coal has filled the country's power for
decades and remains the main energy
source
last year 88 of south africa's
electricity was generated from coal
the state-owned company escom is the
main supplier of the country's
electricity we currently emit about
171 million tons of co2 into the
atmosphere per annum
that accounts for roughly half of
south africa's emissions and south
africa's emissions in turn account for
half of the african continents
emissions so eskimos accountable for a
quarter
of the overall african emissions studies
show south africa has great potential
for wind and solar power generation the
country has been criticized for not
transitioning to renewable energy fast
enough but we don't intend to invest in
any new coal-fired generation so madoop
and kusili will be the last coal-fired
power stations that we built as eskem we
have committed to a net zero goal
in terms of our carbon emissions by
2050. so we are already starting to work
on plans to offset the emission from
those two power stations
to compensate
by
carbon negative projects while those
plans are still being made the country's
call power stations are churning out
carbon emissions into the atmosphere
causing irreversible damage
madupi is expected to do that for
another 50 years
i'm now joined by murefu barasa he is an
energy sector expert based in nairobi
welcome to to dw news africa um
a big question at cop 26 is how
countries can move away from fossil
fuels um but how is this transition
different in africa compared to in
developed nations
if you think of a six-pack you know just
as a beer six pack
developed countries uh have their cans
full the six packs can full
and uh they have a mix of different
technologies
solar wind hydro
and the developing countries have their
six packs empty
so they're trying to to fill this six
pack
with only renewable energy and this is
why the energy transition in developing
countries is fundamentally different
from that in developed countries so you
have a situation where
the transition is is from a situation
where there's maximum energy production
universal energy access and one where
there is none
some wealthy countries are threatening
to stop funding fossil fuel power
projects in in less developed countries
um what would that mean for africa
yeah this is this is simply going to be
detrimental
to africa's goal
of attaining universal access to
electricity by 2030.
so just like i said you know when we
talk about renewable energy we have to
understand that there are different
types of renewable energy so on the one
hand you have what we call intermittent
renewable energy like soil and wind
they're intermittent because wind does
not blow all the time
solar is available during the day and
it's not available at night and you have
dispatchable or on-demand energy sources
like hydrogen geothermal so many african
countries do not have hydrogen
geothermal so you cannot develop a
robust electricity sector without a mix
of this technology so
if there is a moratorium on fossil fuels
then very many african countries are
going to suffer severely because of this
action
you've written that africa needs
gas power and and plants gas power
plants to provide electricity tell us a
little bit more about why
so if you're building a robust
electricity sector
you cannot just build it based on
solar and wind
and if we say that african countries
have to develop just based on renewable
energy and many of these countries do
not have
hydro
and geothermal then what are you left
with you're left with gas as a
transitional
fuel source
and this is not unusual to africa just
this week just this week
the
german chancellor in in in waiting all
of schultz
was categorical that germany will have
to install
new additional gas-fired plants if
they're supposed to if if they're to
transition to higher shares of renewable
energy so if germany that's very
sophisticated advanced you know with all
the technological know-how and the
resources has to build gas power plants
how much more poorer countries that are
just developing the electricity sector
all right and that's where we'll leave
it
is an energy sector expert in nairobi
thank you for your time and your insight
now talking of bringing power to the
millions of africans who are without
let's meet one farmer in eastern rwanda
who was tired of sitting in the dark he
brought electricity to his village and
managed to make it climate friendly at
the same time
israel hibimana was fed up living
without electricity
so he decided to take matters into his
own hands
he built a hydropower plant after
selling two of his houses to buy used
engines and water pipes in kigali
[Music]
i never went to school
the idea for it came to me when i saw a
small hydroelectric plant when i was a
child
that's why when i grew up
i wanted a similar plant
so he could generate electricity in my
village
the plant initially supplied more than
50 families in his village with
electricity
but his first model failed to regulate
the electricity supply and the surges
burned out people's electronics
israel didn't give up the plant was
modernized and expanded with the help of
the rwanda energy group it now
gives power to 170 households
and hundreds of others are in the
process of getting electricity
and light
for the first time
what a pleasure to have electricity
we're finally done with the darkness yes
this schoolgirl is delighted she won't
fall behind in her homework
only one traditional lamp and didn't
have enough food for everyone to use it
at night this stopped me from studying
now i will be able to study longer even
at night time i can perform well at
school
finally having electricity in the
village is also good for business it
enabled this seamstress to double her
output
i used to use manual sewing machines and
that was really difficult
but after electricity came
i bought electric sewing machines
straight away and that's made my life
much easier
many other opportunities have been
created in this village since the
arrival of electricity
thanks to habimana and his hydroelectric
plant
now kumi nadu the environmental activist
is still with me sakumi we've just seen
a very good example there for one energy
solution in a village in rwanda but if
we consider the scale uh to which we
need to electrify africa fossil fuels do
have a record um some voices on the
continent say it's unfair to to limit
emissions on the world's poorest
countries
when emissions are rising in
industrialized countries what do you say
to that well it's unfair sure but
poor nations who are paying now the
first and most brutal impacts of climate
change cannot bury their heads in the
sign sand and say just because they did
a bad thing in the rich countries we
also have a right to continue to do bad
to do a bad thing and let's just be
clear africa is not a poor continent
right africa is the richest continent
underneath the ground and that's
precisely why we're one of the poorest
continent above the ground what is
called the resource curse and let's be
clear that example
from rwanda is the example that should
move us
because a lot of energy that's generated
in big plants and then has to be
transmitted long distances to get to the
villages and so on gets lost in the
process and let's be very clear
most of our governments on the continent
know
that we have huge solar potential huge
wind potential huge wave potential right
because we are a continent right
surrounded by
and on the argument that
it it's uh you know the sun blows it uh
shines at some time and the wind blows
that that problem is being fixed by
advances in battery storage capability
and i would say and i challenge any
african leader to tell me otherwise
right that the reason most governments
around the world are so committed to big
fossil fuel projects at the moment is
because the supply chain of corruption
right is deeper bigger and juicier i'm
not saying that renewable energy is
immune from corruption
but it is much less and so if and and
and if we do not have a decentralized
approach right
rural areas in throughout our continent
we can turn it around very quickly with
small micro solar grids
with the kind of example that we saw
with micro hydro and so on so
i don't buy the argument that many of
our governments make that we have to do
the dirty stuff even though the dirty
stuff is killing us right now and the
unfairness of it is
recognized right and that's why we push
so hard to have this 100 billion a year
in the green climate fund to outpour
countries i have 10 seconds left on the
clock what commitment do you want to see
from africa's leaders going into the
summit
we want them to say
we will take
climate change seriously we will
prioritize the poor in the way we
allocate resources we want advantage
industry at the expense of the people
and that they will put people before
profit and before corruption all right
that's kumi naidu the environmental
activist
thank you so much for that kumi